[Music]
congratulations on the final installment
Fifty Shades I'm taking you away for the
weekend I just can't believe this was my
life that I get to live with you how
tough is it to say goodbye to this
character it doesn't feel tough it feels
it feels pretty great I mean I'm so
grateful and I'm so proud of these
projects and I feel like we we did it
and it was really difficult and I'm
really looking forward to my life given
the platform that it's given me there's
nothing negative about it what was the
toughest part about it for you the
subject matter is is obviously a bit
intense and you may call me mrs. gray so
to have that coupled with the commercial
massive 'ti of the film was difficult to
handle sometimes and then to you know to
get through it and do film one and then
return back and do it again then we shot
the second and third back-to-back so
that was you know like six months of of
filming these scenes that are physically
and emotionally quite vulnerable and
then you know you have the judgement of
essentially the whole world and they
don't hold back
no they don't hold back they do not they
do not those worked as an actor more the
Americans so for many years so no
stranger to doing a lot of love scenes
I'm watching these and it's like
flashbacks from me and I was talking to
Jamie about like how I would prepare for
some of these scenes like I had him
doing push-ups behind sofas and he said
that he said you'd be like getting ready
for a scene like I'm not like like a
normal human and he would be like
dropping down and doing push-ups but
would there be any prep for you serious
psychological preparation which I mean
there is a lot more of my body that's
shown then then Jamie's actually weirdly
he's the one doing all the push-ups
and it's it's not something that's easy
to do I really had to get ready for it
each time and sure and know exactly what
we were gonna do how we were going to
accomplish shooting the scenes the more
intimate ones
and over the course of the three films
that never got easier luckily Jamie and
I you know were were so comfortable with
each other and it felt safe and
protected but it's still an environment
that's scary Jamie said he got to the by
the time the third movie he got to the
point where you know if he saw some
scenes where he'd be shirtless or
whatever he'd be able to kind of
negotiate a couple of those having a
little bit more clothing on at times
when he thought it made sense in the
film and for the character would you as
well or did you just kind of like follow
along with what was written there for
you I tried to do a lot of negotiating
and a lot of different things the thing
is that I mean that's it's a really big
part of these stories you're sure so
it's not it's not like I I know what I
signed up for yeah so it's not really a
matter of it's not like they're forcing
me to take off my clothes it was I I
chose to do these jobs